I've just been kind of sitting here like, hmm,
hmm, relaxing a bit with the vibes.
Yay!
My tummy hurt today.
My tummy hurt.
So, it must be, it must be because of my debt.
the greatest tragic tragedy again my tummy is still hoarding
it's okay it's okay i'm gonna smash my frustrations out on
little piggy banks this is bills must be paid i'm still
recovering from sickness and jet lag and everything
I was like, you know what, I really want something kind
of...
I don't know if that... I feel like this game is kind of
chill.
I just beat Metal Gear in 1987.
My first Metal Gear game, and that's the credits roll, I get
a ping that Minto is live.
Let's go.
I hope you had fun!
Tell me, Hort be gone.
Yeah!
We weren't supposed to eat money.
I know it's green.
I'm afraid of green things right now.
Green foods.
Feels like they're all scary at the moment.
it the music sounds chill at least right i don't know i'm
just oh man my i'm so i couldn't take a nap today i couldn't
i tried which is probably for the best oh gosh it's probably
for the best that i can actually sleep tonight and hopefully
get over the the jet lag
the body rejecting a nap is crazy I struggle sleeping home
because like I want to sleep but then my body's like no girl
you need to haunt like you gotta get up girl get up you
gotta go haunting my tummy hort too explosive type
are you pause feel better thank you glitter gold and brandon
welcome back to thank you thank you thank you
not the explosive type feel better beam music is a bomb i
will i will be better eventually but today actually i ended
up being quite productive with some things that i have
planned in the future i was i was in a bit and making i was
writing things down i was you know that gif of or not gif
but that scene in haruhi it is a gif though you know of like
haru yuki typing really really fast that was me that was me
today me too cute feel better soon thank you for remix thank
you game is a lot of fun i think you'll enjoy it i'm excited
let her cook the video game episode i think I forgot, I
posted about it.
But, um, I didn't really talk about it.
There was a 20, oh gosh, I can't even say it.
It's too painful.
Maybe this is why my tummy hurts.
So, thank you for the pink.
What the heck?
Thank you!
There was a, um, there was a 20, 20 year anniversary Haruhi
Suzumiya exhibit.
Oh gosh.
Psychic damage.
I can't even say it.
It's so bad.
And I went, it was an Ike Bakuro while I was in Japan.
um Rin, thank you so much for the so much heart.
Thank you for that.
Um, what was I saying?
Oh, there was a, uh, the exhibit.
And it was like, it can't be that old.
It's, oh my gosh, it gives me brain damage, for real.
And it was right next to a Zero Nozukaima 20-year
anniversary exhibit.
I guess 2006 was like just the greatest year ever for anime
or something.
Not to say that Zero Nozukaima is, you know, but...
truly a golden age crazy when i went to the exhibit and it
was really really nice um hold on let me look at my pictures
to kind of um they had some really cool things that like
like a bunch of you know key visual art and uh like
commentary from the directors and and Sayu and lots of, lots
of like, scale things.
Like, for example, they had like a miniature version of the
club of the, like the SOS Dan room, club room.
And that was really cool.
And then they had like, they had like a somewhat, like they
had like half the classroom made, like a model of it um they
had they had like the room as it was in in in suzumi harohi
no whatever was it the movie and they had like yuki's
blanket and everything and i was like oh my god i'm gonna
cry and then moviecore thank you for the fucking thing and
then then they had oh gosh they had so much the one thing
they had that was pretty cool was they had the backdrop of
of you know you could dance the Hare Hare Yukai in front of
the backdrop which um nobody else was doing I tried it I did
I did do it and i was just like i haven't thought of this
dance or not thought of it but i have not properly learned
this dance in 20 years but i still got it baby and oh
um uh it was fun it was cute one thing that's really nice is
uh sorry my brain is like i i really needed that nap today.
I should have napped.
I should have napped but I didn't nap.
I couldn't nap.
One thing about like exhibits and stuff like this in Japan
is they're sometimes very strange about taking photos,
right?
Or videos and things like that.
There were some things that you weren't able to take photos
of.
For example, it was like storyboard stuff.
They're like, nah, we don't want you taking photos of that.
um uh they were like uh say you voice actor signatures and
stuff like that they didn't want you taking photos of that
um there was a video that they were playing of like god
knows and they had like a little stage looking setup and
they didn't want you to take a video of that um but um but
for the little area that you could do the Haru Haru you guy
they were like yeah please video okay picture okay I don't
know Japan is just quite strict on some of these rules
sometimes um um
um the new AI capabilities no this has been like forever
this has been a thing in Japan forever forever forever like
just going to like certain places and they're they just i
don't know i guess it's like a privacy thing um but also i
did notice that at the end of the exhibit i don't know if
this is i mean this is not the case with everything but uh
but uh they did have a book that had all the things that you
couldn't take photos of in the book and it's like the more
rare stuff right like the like so you know maybe they were
just trying to get you to buy the book one of my favorite
memories in japan is walking around nishinomiya for a day
visiting places from haruji that's so nice i love pilgrimage
stuff like that privacy and copyright laws are very
different in japan they are they're very different there is
no what's the word uh uh fair use is that the one there is
no it is for use right yeah yeah yeah so mmm they're very
careful about that the pharmacy is a shortage of my meds no
no Ren that sucks I'm so sorry yeah we can chill and smash
some piggy banks unfair use that's unfair and why say he
made us sicky
Thank you, though, for going to the concert.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really glad you liked my Minto chords.
Yes!
Wait, the Seifuku one was so cute.
I loved the hat.
Yeah.
New rules.
Minto can use it whenever she wants it.
So it is unfair.
So we call it unfair use.
Yeah.
I use it whenever I want.
Oh.
Trying to see what else there was.
I did do that.
Why did I think of Haruhi?
Why did I think of that?
I don't quite remember.
Whatever.
I had a lot of fun at...
Here we see!
I'll be recovering from your jet lag soon.
We don't like you!
I just need a couple more days, baby.
It's always confusing with you.
So are you and you go multiple time zones, right?
It's like I have to go Japan to New York and then back to my
maid cafe.
I'm just, and you know, it's one thing, especially like, you
know, in New York, I was like, I'm jet lagged, but I don't
really want to fix my schedule because I'm going to be
fixing, I'm going to be changing it again.
So much.
So, but now I'm all, I'm all messed up.
how is welcome to mint cafe almost a year old oh don't say
that wait that's terrifying
i've only been to okinawa but it was neat to see the source
of many anime traditions like lausen i guess lausen would be
in okinawa too huh time is moving scary scary i would
working on some birthday stuff too today as well so do you
see that Ryukishi 7 is giving a tour of Shirakawa Go to 30
people no way I'm afraid it's been nine years super cheery
I'll hope you become a messed up soon.
Me too.
Don't say, don't say, don't say yawn, please.
Or else I yawn.
I am too weak.
I can't think about yawning.
I can't read yawning.
I can't speak yawning.
Or else I will yawn.
I am the most easily influenced ghost ever.
no
jet lag was brutal when i went i bet what do you think zach
i'm so easy stop saying i can't properly yawn i'm trying to
talk at the same time you know when you're like okay you can
yawn but a proper yawn is when you get it in the back of
your throat you know what i'm talking about the bzm isn't
helping i feel I feel like I'm in like a eternal elevator.
Thanks for the concert, Minky.
Welcome back.
It's such a fun time seeing y'all from Up in the Orchestra.
Strider, thank you.
Oh my God, this is all your fault.
I wasn't this bad until you guys started.
I guess I can forgive the jet tag.
I was fine until you guys started.
No, you guys are gonna make me sleepy oh there it is i got
the prop for you on it okay shall we pay our bills everybody
oh whoa i i didn't even mean to click it you are broke all
that's left are bills past due notices and a hammer for some
reason piggy banks are jumping on your desk so do what feels
right comma ket to comma day Wait, that's kind of good.
I'm proud.
Thank you so much for the...
For the...
Here you go, Mint.
This should help pay for some of your snack built from
Comic-Cit.
No, I'm buying snacks.
Thank you so much for the hug and sofa.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, great.
It's just a heck.
Yo.
Hi, Batman.
Glad you got a proper yard.
Thanks.
Grab your...
Stop saying yarn.
Honestly, I was, I feel I was pretty good at Comiket.
I had my list of things I wanted to get, and I got those
things, and I only strayed a little bit.
I only strayed a little.
Yeah, helping my Oshi get out of debt from buying all those
doujins.
I'm sad to start using my second bookshelf we after four
days of AMYC yeah right New York is so expensive too at
least Japan it feels like funny money at the moment a little
bit but I did so I took out like a but like I don't want to
say how much i took out a couple hundred dollars no well i
guess yeah with the conversion rate it would still be a
couple hundred dollars and i was like i will have so much
left over i like to one thing that i suggest if you are
going to japan is like you know while you're there
withdrawing a bunch of money if you plan on going back
because maybe the next time you go back the yen will have
gotten
but your yen bills will not or they will be you know you
don't have to you won't have such a crazy conversion you
know what I mean so yeah all this yachting is right
I was responsible at off guy but I did get haul envy you
have you have haul envy until you have literally no space in
your Cafe, you know.
Leftover money from Comic-Cat?
Funny joke.
Yeah, I did not have any left.
I did not.
I did not have any leftover.
Oopsie.
But I got everything I wanted.
So, yippee!
Yes, our piggy banks are jumping.
Do what feels right.
Am I gonna kill this guy?
Oh my god!
Wait, I'm not even clicking.
It just does it itself.
Oh, my hand is tired.
My accuracy... There's a...
Wait!
clicks 42!
I didn't even I wasn't even clicking!
I wasn't clicking!
Heavy-handed.
I'll pay for that, yeah.
Look at this.
There's a skill tree for caffeine addiction.
Swing faster.
Bigger hammer.
Extra loot.
Plus 20 stamina.
Okay.
These all sound pretty good.
Oh, no.
Okay, so I don't even have to click it seems because it's
like clicking on its own you know I'm getting sleepy it's
clicking oh my hand just gives up it's it says it's you're
saying it's a clicker game but I'm not clicking I'm just
hovering over the piggies just gotta track the piggy banks
okay cool see we got i got 12 i can upgrade i can upgrade i
think more loot sounds most beneficial because then we can
get more money to then do everything right now i'm i'm broke
there are no useless clicks here oh yeah boy oh i got a gold
i got a gold Oh.
Complete a run with 100% accuracy!
Upgrade.
Let's do...
Attack spade, maybe?
Nice job.
Nice.
Two.
Three.
One.
Two.
Three.
One.
Two.
Three!
One!
Two!
Oh!
the pig sniper okay we're already like killing it though I
think I'm gonna do more stamina and then we'll do the bigger
hammer this is already kind of chill when I'm so sleepy hey
don't oh jackpot when I'm so sleepy I just want like it's
really hard sometimes for me to think of games to play
because I'm like my brain is not at max is not at a capacity
that i can comprehend so happen to me like five oh my gosh
are you looking forward to mgs for this week yes i know it
is an odd thing to be excited for a game release and checks
note 2008 but i'm personally looking forward to putting
steak on the microwave again for dh wait for for dh for
4k HD.
I mean, thank you.
I'm so excited.
I think I want to play MGS4 again.
I might do it as like a member stream.
And like some Peace Walker.
Maybe, I don't know.
Maybe Peace Walker so that we can do multiplayer.
Um.
4 dimensional I'm just so excited I wish almost that I had
waited to play Until now Because now I want to replay it
Why not both?
Yeah
Doki needs to see the beach scenes I see you're spending
money but there are bills to be paid don't forget to pay Oh
I have enough money oh my gosh that's so scary Spank thank
you so much for the tour today Nolo thank you oh so you're
in debt here I hope this helps a little I thank you I thank
you
I paid my bill Pay your first build.
I wonder if that's why they give you jackpot right before.
Hi, wife.
Hi, Tascol.
We can get a thing.
5% loot from Peggy's.
Destroying a Piggy has 5% chance to spawn five circling orbs
that damage Piggy's they hit.
Unhit 4% chance to drop a magnet that pulls nearby Piggy's
together.
I think I'm going to go to 5% loot, though, because...
This seems guaranteed.
5% and 4% chance are so low.
No?
This game?
Bills must be paid.
It's too real.
But it's so fun, actually.
Orbs?
You think the orbs?
I feel like loot.
But if you're hitting faster, I guess that's true.
Oh, we'll try the orbs.
Other people want me to try orbs.
I'll try orbs.
More pinkies.
20% attack speed.
energy loot from oh 30 percent loot from all whoa that's a
lot six percent luck higher chance for better loot let's get
the bigger hammer and more loot i have zero money next
i'm gonna focus on my speed or maybe stamina would be good
well speed and stamina kind of go hand in hand so Yeah, so I
have to save my money for the...
So $45 will be due.
Ooh!
In four days.
Sunburned, lazy, and mostly just stands there.
Smashing him, restore stamina.
What?
Oh, wait.
Upgrades?
Where's my skill tree?
Oh, here.
Okay, interesting.
$50.
All right, we'll get them more energy.
Oh, geez, this is bad.
Wait, this is so bad.
Is he gonna die?
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, please smash.
Please smash!
That seemed like not so great.
Can you take some more hits?
This was $50, but I'm not sure if we'll be able to get it
before.
Our bills are due.
For now, we'll start getting the guys that we know we can
get really easily.
Alright.
Smash.
You have to wonder if they deserved it with the pickies.
Maybe.
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm doing it.
I'm doing it faster speeds we need that we need it we need
it oh my gosh please I wish I could hit harder whoa what was
that oh nice oh nice nice nice oh this is huge oh shoot I
missed one ah whoa that was huge that was a good that was
good that was good insanely clutch are there no function to
charge your hammer strikes on there maybe not yet maybe not
yet a hundred dollars though heck yeah oh five percent
chance of destroyed piggy explodes heck yeah collateral
damage 25 percent of your base damage when you swing It hits
two plus piggies.
Very interesting.
Stronger grip, less effort.
Ooh.
More damage.
That's just something we need.
I think we can afford both.
I want that, this though.
This grip strength.
Grit.
gorilla grip.
We'll do the collateral.
I want to try it out.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, nice!
Come on.
Nice!
Oh, nice.
That was close.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Come on.
Let's get this guy.
Nice.
Oh.
We're making Buku Buku Buku.
now.
Nice.
Collateral is for multi-hits, though.
You only hit one at a time.
Oh, I did not read.
I'm paying my bills.
Bills must be paid or bankruptcy.
This almost gives a chill clover pit.
I feel like it starts kind of slow like clover pit, and it
will go insanely, insane-o style later on.
Every five seconds, there's a 10% chance to mark and destroy
a random piggy that's pretty big each different piggy type
you destroy this run adds plus 0.5 percent loot oh clover
pig yeah let's go with liquid this one seems the best i'd
say um
what what is our next bill 200 we can get that in how many
days five days oh yeah I'm also gonna do more luck.
Okay.
And you know what?
Screw it.
We go all in.
Whoa!
Oh, dang it.
Yes.
Come on.
Nice.
The multi-hits, baby.
Oh, we've already almost made back the money.
Will we continue?
Oh.
Nice.
Yeah, just stand there like good little piggies.
Yeah.
Come on.
Oh, thank you.
I've wasted one.
I think we won't make it.
Maybe we'll.
Ah, no.
This game looks like a game.
so relaxing i'm i'm enjoying myself what do we have
destroyed biggies have a seven plus seven percent chance to
drop double loot okay these are quite expensive
we will hold off for what is this oh lightning strike what's
this phantom hand that's me a thousand dollars guys i'm
pricey Stand here like a...
Standing here like a cute little piggy.
Whoa, Jackpot!
Yeah.
Stand there.
Piggy.
Huge!
Oh, thank you, I wasted one.
I think we can get this guy.
I think we can...
I think we can crack him.
Yeah.
One more.
And that's it.
You found the shop.
Spend your...
cash on hammers and gadgets.
Uh-oh.
What does that mean?
The shop.
We can get...
Wait, I want the peeko peeko hammer!
Wait, what are these?
Clover...
No.
Not the Clover pot.
Piggy timer.
Spawns a new piggy every 10 seconds.
Incense drain.
Reduces their stamina drain.
Spiked hammer I want the pico-pico hammer
What's collection?
Oh, shoppish Hmm So they're trying to get rid of this red
dot here Um, attack speed Critical chance The phantom hands
The phantom hands got Coma Ket money that needs replenishing
So she has to charge a little extra Catch these phantom
hands.
New piggies arrive every seven seconds during a run.
Start each run with plus two more piggy.
Fah!
10% more damage.
We need $200 in two days.
I think we can do it.
Wider swing rate is.
Nice.
This guy's just standing here.
He's standing here.
Standing here.
Yes, more money, more money, more money.
I don't think we got this one.
That's okay, though.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, all right.
More damage, more good.
Yeah, yeah, that's how I'm feeling.
All right, we can't spend any more money, though.
Let's go, let's go.
All right.
That guy's fast.
Two flags for the pink!
I don't think we got this guy, unfortunately.
Great job at the contrary though!
Sorry to...
the...
the people behind you whose view...
my tall edge was blocking.
The Supa's in their honor.
No!
Oh no!
Thank you for going though, thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's pay our bills.
Our bills have been paid.
Amito and I was like, yeah, sure hope we can scrape enough
cash for your debt be dope.
And if you got a little on the side, I need to buy more.
No, come on.
You spilled all your paint.
Oh, mo.
That's your ult.
You spilled the paint.
It's all gone.
They took it.
Let's see what we got.
Plus 3% luck.
Higher chance for better loot.
Each coin has a 1% chance.
to convert to gems?
Unhit, 2% chance to get 1.5 hit radius for three swings.
I'm gonna go with luck.
I
mean, that one went to AMIC but didn't see you at the
concert.
But I did hang with a friend who was cosplaying as you, so
close enough.
Sounds fun hanging in with your friend, so...
What's the next bill?
$740!
Okay.
Maybe 15% loot.
We'll do that.
More money.
Come on.
So many biggies on my...
Am I, like, hallucinating?
Or is this, like...
You know?
Is this...
Am I just committing lots of murder?
You know?
Oof.
162.
Not that...
Not so much, not so much.
When's, where's a, let's see.
More speed, 450.
I wish this guy would move.
Wasting my orbs, wasting my orbs.
Nice, oh, I wasted a hit too.
Yeah.
Come on.
No, no good.
We have seven days still.
We have seven days.
Seven days.
I meant not important news, but dinosaurs have been
confirmed to exist in strange real.
Imagine the name.
Wait, no way.
Wait, when did they confirm this?
I think that's important news.
I think that's very important news.
Let's aim for the 450 attack speed.
Oh, nice.
Just cross that guy off our list.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
No.
Times 4.
Nice.
Whoa, what was that?
That was pretty crazy.
Smash 100.
Piggies.
New coin.
Double.
What's for the piggy bank?
Superliving on that girl.
It happened all so fast.
What is this?
Oh, Piggy takes it all.
The Piggy takes it all.
The loser pays their debt.
Hopefully, number doubles your current runs loot.
The piggy takes it all.
Spector, thank you so much for the 20.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Dang it, I was trying to get them together.
Yeah.
Smash!
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Lucky.
Lucky break.
Come on.
I don't think I'm gonna get him, but dang it, so close.
I'm gonna try again.
Tangshu!
Binto never lucky.
I was wondering if you've ever seen a movie called Escape
from New York.
I have!
Actually, I did do a watch- I've watched someone do a
watch-along of it years ago.
Thank you, Bill, for this every time.
Though I have not seen the sequel.
More attack speed.
Wait, when's our build due?
Four days?
We can make it back.
Dang it, I was trying to get them together.
Yeah.
Nice.
Jackpot!
Oh, shoot.
I'm wasting.
Oh, so close.
Can we make it back?
I don't know.
I think they're telling us about this is...
Wait, do you think they're telling us this isn't about
gambling?
And it's a game about smashing ceramic animals for money?
SCAM?
Do it?
Okay.
Ah!
Yes!
Oh, it feels so good when you win.
We had to win at some point!
That's how it works!
Oh, the triple.
The double.
the triple
you also kind of have to like pay attention to where you're
smashing you know because they'll like pop up oh we're not
gonna make it oh big money big money big money I'll doubt
you more often I guess yeah we're almost to a new piggy
that's so exciting I'm just gonna
maybe we have two days left
yeah I got cheated i got cheated you this is a chill game
this is a chill game
chill game chill game chill game chill game chill game chill
chill chill chill chill chill chill chill chill chill chill
chill chill chill chill that was like my best run i'll never
forgive them for taking it from me i'll never forgive them
no don't worry but they'll start doubting you so You can't
get the good point, Nip.
Works every time.
Wait, never mind.
You got it.
No.
I'll be doing okay, but I haven't got it in time.
It's okay.
Thank you, Nyan.
Hey, Minto, I was thinking about you.
I can't come to many things, but I'm happy to see you
streaming again.
One day I'll be able to go to all concerts and stuff.
I appreciate you just hanging out with us here, too, fall
and night.
No worries at all.
Doing one day.
We'll get the money.
the money look at the money where's my buddy mike wazowski
where's the money mike wazowski where's the money mike
wazowski where's the money mike wazowski where's the money
mike wazowski mike wazowski mike wazowski mike wazowski come
on come on come on come on oh
No, no, no.
I paid my bill.
5% tax speed.
Each run has a 20% chance to scatter four table spikes.
Piggy's passing through them take 20% of your base damage
every five seconds.
Oh, sorry, 0.5 seconds.
On hit, 4% chance to drop a magnet that pulls nearby piggy
together.
we're Domingue Lobowski
magnet seems fun yeah magnet seems cool I'm gonna go for
faster swings though free faster swings seems pretty good
yikes yikes yikes yikes yeah I'm gonna move you guys over a
teeny tiny bit so you guys can see the amount of money that
I have a little better how many days do we have i didn't
even see oh nice that was clean that was clean come on can't
you guys walk close to each other
oh shoot ah i'm throwing i'm throwing
i'm throwing i'm sorry to my damn sir thank you so much for
the five gift I'm in Taekong Musi.
Hello, hello.
In four days?
I can't do that.
Unless.
Okay.
More piggies might be good.
Because that's more money.
Am I...
I have four?
Okay, the run is saved.
The run is saved.
Don't worry about it.
Come on.
Die already.
Get smashed, little piggy.
We have a new piggy.
Woody.
Barely moves.
Build like a log.
You need patience for this one.
Oh, I got plus $9 because of that.
I feel like I want to get more skills, but like I feel
like...
I feel like...
Oh, shoot.
I didn't mean to do that.
That's fine.
Oh, shoot.
No!
It says you guys barely move.
of movement going on here there's so much movement happening
here nice oh four hundred dollars though that's huge that's
huge I mean we've already we've already made the money so
okay tomorrow's we'll double or nothing tomorrow's we'll
double or nothing for the next one huge huge huge huge
That was huge.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Yes.
I'm going to go after him here.
Come on.
Ah!
It's okay.
I paid my bill.
Yeah, the wood ones are tough.
Plus 15 max stamina, but minus 5% base stamina.
Damage.
Uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh.
Stamina for damage.
Lucky swing, a 25% chance to start each run with 20 plus 25%
hit radius for the whole run.
Or more loot.
I have to think more loot.
Everybody agrees.
I'm scared.
Oh!
I'm gonna get it.
It's really beneficial to try and, like, get them all
together like this, you know?
That's why the magnet would be pretty good.
Come on.
Oh my god!
You're flashing red, please!
Ugh!
I think the run is over, everybody.
We'll see.
The run is saved!
Oh,
it's so over.
Everybody?
It was nice knowing you.
Wow.
It was nice knowing you all.
It was so nice knowing you all.
It was an honor.
Being...
You're a piggy.
Oh, nice.
You're a piggy destroyer.
You got a double.
I think I do, actually.
Wait, how do I go back?
Is there a way to let me double?
I guess not.
Shoot.
Oh.
Wow.
Strong start.
Let's go.
I thought these guys weren't supposed to move much.
This game is such a lie.
Just like when they said that my cat wouldn't be a screamer.
And then all the time she was just like...
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Double.
Yeah, they are fast too.
But still.
We have one day.
There's no way.
What if I pay it?
Alright, let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Give me more.
Stop moving.
Please.
Please, I don't...
Ah, he's not gonna break.
We're not gonna break him.
Oh no!
I'm not surprised you're bankrupt with that many bills.
What are you even doing?
with your money i'd better not ask but no worries i've got
something for you you paid five bills for a total amount of
2015 dollars that makes 40 legacy points you get one for
every 50 you pay in bills fifty dollars oh plus two damage
max stamina increases by 10 piggy loot is 10 higher Each run
starts with two extra piggies.
We'll grab this.
We'll grab the loot.
1 million!
Full crit, yeah, but I couldn't even afford it.
I had 40.
It's the end of the month.
Go main.
Thank you, no thank you.
I love a game with some legacy, right?
Oh yeah, rogue-like upgrades.
Wait.
Piggy loot is 10% higher.
Glowing Piggy chance.
We haven't even seen a glowing Piggy.
Start cycle two.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even realize how slow you start out as.
You know?
But I'm stronger now.
I am.
I'm stronger now.
Oh, what's this?
I could already double or nothing?
No way!
Yippee!
I got an achievement for it, too.
Like, go all in.
Nice.
Never punished.
More energy is good.
Tax speed good.
More grip.
Never punished.
Oh, yeah.
Don't you know that's my middle name.
I feel like when they run faster, they have better loot.
Is that my copium or is that real?
Wait, can I break the cup?
Oh, nope.
The tourist is back!
Yes.
yes yes yes
oh I think we should do the more damage I'll continue here
whoa
I'm getting them with one hit now that's crazy holy cow oh
sure shoot oh my my accuracy dang it damage is always nice
yeah the damage was crazy right
oh well it's a good thing i can pay declare bankruptcy oh i
guess if you want to like do more things okay each coin has
a five percent chance to duplicate itself Whoa, the circling
orbs!
I wish that these were higher, higher chance.
I declare bankruptcy!
How large is the skill tree?
Oh, four hits.
One, two, three, four.
Ooh, ooh.
One, two, three, four, oh, oh, one, two, three, come on,
four, night hole, come on.
I should have been able to get that one.
Mornings!
I haven't done the bigger hammer yet.
But more damage.
Just pay the bill in advance.
No, no, no.
That gives us less time.
time.
Actually, though, what happens?
I wonder if you pay it in advance.
Because we'll have, do you get money?
That doesn't make any sense.
Save for the hammer.
The toy hammer.
I think you guys are right.
Okay, yeah, we'll do that.
Paying in advance can give bonuses.
It can.
I'll try it this time because it's low.
Look.
Better loot.
Each coin has 1% chance to convert to gem.
Every 3 seconds, there's a 20% chance to freeze all piggies
for 2.5 seconds.
Frozen piggies take plus 10% damage.
That's 20% chance.
It's not bad.
Maximum pico-pico.
I'm going to try the deep freeze.
Alright, let's try it.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Heck yeah.
It doesn't feel like a rhythm game, but you have to keep
your eyes, like, peeled, you know what I mean?
Like, to see where the next piggy spawn and everything.
Oh, he's just frozen in place there.
Oh, shoot.
Like, I end up missing some of them because of it.
If I get double or nothing here?
No!
I meant not the nothing.
I meant if I get double.
I'm gonna get the attack speed.
What is that?
Two, three, four, one.
One, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, one, two,
three, four, one, one, two, three, four, one.
Ah, so close.
Hello, Minto.
Hello, Spector!
Telephone found only one number is saved.
Big Tony.
You might lend you money, but what's the catch?
Big Tony, you say.
Gosh, the song, like, the...
It was so good.
Okay, we're gonna...
If I double it...
It's gonna be huge
I got cheated I got cheated.
I absolutely got cheated.
You know what?
I should just go to Vegas because I would win every time
there
Absolutely scammed scammed
To Three, four.
They wouldn't cheat me in Vegas.
One, two, oh.
Okay, I'm gonna save up for the hammer.
Never.
You're getting rid of all the bad luck.
All right, last one.
Last try, last try.
Yes!
Some of these are, like, free.
Like $35 is free.
You know what I mean?
It's free.
Girl math.
No, no, no.
In Vegas, they're the hammer and you're the bank.
Two, three, four, two, three, four.
Thank you, Spank.
Four, dog, three, three.
Chat, I really appreciate...
Dang it!
One, two...
Ah.
All right.
Tomorrow, we'll get the pico-pico.
Oh, wait.
What do we say?
Wait.
Well, when we say that about Super Chats...
No, no, no, it's different.
It's different.
$10 is like a meal.
This is free?
I'm not so sure.
No, no, no.
$35 is free.
free caveat no when i'm making 262 dollars 35 is basically
free oh oh one two three four oh one two three four one one
two three four one one two three four one One, one, one,
two, three, four, one, one, one, one, one.
Oh, so Streamlabs is free.
No!
Oh, wow.
We made a lot.
Wait, we actually can get it though.
No, no, no, no.
Call Big Tony.
No, pay the bill.
And one extra day before bills become overdue!
less interest on every loan.
Tony wouldn't charge me a loan.
I know that guy.
One extra day.
Huge.
Free!
It's not free!
Here we go.
Nice.
We got the Pico Pico hammer.
Thank you guys for that.
So much, I'll stop it.
Two, three, four, whoa, whoa, holy two, three, one, oh, my
whole setup is now different.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Now, where is your Vegeta costume?
Why am I going to be a Vegeta costume?
I think we need more pigs.
1, 1, 2, 3, 1, 1, 1, 2, 3, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, it's too
fast!
My accuracy has gone way down!
Holy money!
Hello, Vito, hello, Dusty!
Thank you!
Holy cow.
Whoa, money.
Huge money.
Huge, huge money.
We'll start with more piggies.
More damage.
What's, how much is the bill?
750.
And we have eight days to pay it.
Let's keep going.
I need my...
I think this one has a much smaller hit radius.
Okay.
Because I have before I didn't have to be nearly as precise
and now I feel like I'm having to be super precise with it
Woody isn't gonna stand a chance.
Don't say that Swing area if I buy this I yeah, we still
have seven days seven days Shockwave would be good too Oh
whoa Huge
okay come on come on bring home a big box please nice
shockwave would be good could deal some damage if you miss
yeah yeah well double or nothing we got this oh we actually
got this yeah okay awesome I will do shockwave then oh wait
we have the phantom hand
big money big money big money glowing pig wait piggies have
a point three percent chance to spawn glowing glowing
piggies are guaranteed jackpot dropping the highest possible
loot tier
i'm gonna grab that one we still have enough to pay the bill
lightning strike okay let's just keep going let's see how
this all works out
Alright, yeah.
Whoa!
The shockwave!
The shockwave happened!
It was huge.
Oh, come on.
No, don't give me one of these guys.
Give me a stamina guy, please.
Jackpot!
$1,000 in a single run!
Should we?
Yeah.
Ha!
How many times have I lost the 50%, you guys?
How many times have I lost a 50%?
That was a lot of money.
That was a lot of money that escaped from my hands.
Most of the time.
What is our bill?
Oh, we're still at the 750.
We're killing it.
What's this?
one?
Destroying a pickie has a plus 4% chance to restore plus two
stamina.
I won more than not.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm glad I got that other guy in, though.
Everything meant are you having a good week?
I am!
I hope you're having a good week.
Oh, how rough.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, the world is our oyster.
Honestly, I feel like I'm just gonna pay this bill, though.
We're paying it a little bit early.
On hit, there's a 3% chance to add a new piggy to the desk.
Oh.
But our loot bonus is almost at 100%.
But Piggy Chance.
We do hit a lot.
Let's try Piggy Chance.
Alright.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
I don't have any critical chance.
Or not any, but you know.
I feel like more crit chance is pretty good.
And this one.
How many days do I have?
Six days.
Okay.
Nice.
Yes, come together.
Yes, yes.
Yes, walk over here.
You're so attracted to this pig.
Nice.
Not my best, but not my worst.
I'd love to hear you sing some outcasts someday.
Really?
We could try that.
I don't know so much outcasts, though.
Double or nothing.
Boink!
Let's go.
What's this?
Coin rain.
Rain of coins!
Coin rain banks an extra 10% of each destroyed piggy's loot.
Keep smashing until it bursts and pays off.
Oh.
Let's do more piggies.
And this one too.
How many of these?
Five days.
Come on.
Yes.
Be in my orbs.
Congrats on 450k.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I did hit 450k.
That's pretty nifty.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Rage mode!
Every 10th hit has a 5% chance to trigger rage mode,
granting 50% attack speed for three seconds.
Faster swings.
I already feel like I'm so fast.
Your first hit on each piggy deals plus 25% of your base
damage.
Ooh!
Let's try that.
Yes.
Destroy all of them.
it's good to get the stamina guys on so I can at least try
to have, you know, get some more stamina stuff.
Why not hammer upgrade?
Because I don't really have one at the moment.
I guess like the shockwave damage.
Oh wait!
Oh, I just saw the more hammer damage.
Wait, when's my build due in three days?
We can do it.
Trust.
Oh my gosh.
There's a piggy party over there.
Piggy party!
Nice.
Oh!
Oh my god.
$6,000!
Holy!
Oh my god!
No!
We can get the hammer!
Surgical precision.
Grits hit hard.
But it's slower?
That's okay.
We can increase our speed.
Like so.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Wow!
2000.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
It is quite slow.
It's definitely... I don't mind the slowness but I do want
oh why did I do that um we'll make it back we'll make it
back I'll be able to pay my bill I promise this
guy's almost down too
yeah huge money we're we're going crazy style now pay 10
bills drain 5% less stamina while Pigies are frozen.
5% is like nothing, though.
Each run starts with plus one Piggy.
That's huge.
10% loot, but every bill is due one day earlier.
No.
Even though that kind of cancels out with my current thing,
but whatever.
We're smashing crazy style.
Yeah, actually.
Our bill is for 2700.
It actually feels doable this time.
It actually feels doable.
more attack speed wait when how many days oh six days okay I
have to work up to attack speed though I'm gonna try missing
two in a row throws a tantrum oh
crit would go well yeah that's what I was thinking we spend
all our money but we'll make it back
whoa Wow!
Huge!
Come on.
Yes.
Get this extra stamina.
Extra stamina.
I don't think we'll be able to do it, though.
Dang it.
Wow!
I might be insane.
Let's go.
The next one is 50,000.
sturdy hammer made for efficient swings.
Wait, can I buy these things yet?
Oh, I can!
Spawns a new piggy every 10 seconds.
First hit of each run deals two times damage.
It's kind of...
Now I feel like I have so much money.
I'm like, what about... Decision paralysis or something.
Hmm.
The Phantom Yeah, we can do that one for sure.
Oh, I don't like this motion, I think.
The lightning idea.
Oh, yeah, it's cheap, too.
It's cheap.
More crit.
Wait.
Oh, I should have done this one.
well like this one gives us more chance this one gives us
more hit it's fine more chance is better i think to be
honest the glowing golden yeah let's get that one too okay
we still have five days so we can do more uh 10 percent loot
from all sources more money get all the cheap stuff right
what is cheap anymore though look at that one okay oh
what the heck was that was that the phantom hand oh we're
almost gonna get this guy he seems he seems mean though
no i lost it's fine we have we have time Do you have time?
We'll make it back.
We'll make it back, I guess.
Whoa, what was that?
That was crazy.
Glowing piggy!
Jackpot.
The Phantom Hand!
New coin.
When hit, it gets angry and runs into other piggies.
Dealing 70% of your base damage wait that's kind of huge no
we got a new coin what's our coin oh every 10th hit has a 10
percent chance to deal 10 times damage let's go oh uh sounds
good yeah
three days more oh maybe okay
whoa it's like crowded now you know It's great.
Okay, I need to get this guy, though.
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey!
Oh, oh, we made a lot of money, though.
Nice.
I can do some more upgrades, honestly.
I'm trying to get, like, the cheaper stuff.
Like, this?
Yeah.
more stamina that's big that's big some of the cheaper stuff
yeah okay attack speed well we don't have an upgrade for
attack speed right now let's see I don't even see one that's
for regular attack speed just lightning whatever this is
rage mode we'll get it not two days yeah we're fine rage
lasts longer rage chance let's try it
huge nice we got a jackpot on something and it was one of
our bigger pickies too very nice very nice oh yeah yeah yeah
we'll just continue i'm just gonna continue oh what how did
i miss two hits already Yikes!
I'm raging!
Nice!
Thank you, Phantom Hand.
Did I?
No, I didn't get that last guy, unfortunately.
Alright, let's pay our bills.
I'm raging on them.
Minus 0.2 stamina drain per second.
Each big difference.
type of thing you destroy adds plus 0.5% loot.
Huh.
The skill is not to use so it must be good.
Table spikes.
Oh, that one.
I'm gonna go with the stamina though.
And what's our bill?
5,800.
400,000!
Crazy.
Crazy work.
Oh, combo.
Unlocks combos.
Every 10 combo it's had...
It hit adds plus 2% to your base damage.
Miss and it resets to zero.
Oof.
I haven't been doing so hot, though.
We'll do the coin rain.
Oh, golden.
Nice.
Sometimes it's so hard to see.
This is a guy golden too?
Oh, nice.
We're making, like, mega money now.
It's crazy.
In fact, I'm going to double or nothing it.
Let's go.
Next hammer win?
Well, it's $50,000, so I think we might want to...
I'm going to get some of these, though.
Reduces your stamina drain.
Mini slot machine, big jackpots.
We can get them a why?
An ancient stone.
Each run has a 40% chance to wake and destroy one to four of
the strongest piggies.
Heck yeah.
And a table spinner.
This is going to go...
This is $10 million.
Malai, Malai, Malai.
I will get this one, though.
The combo.
Wombo combo.
10.
Plus 10 max stamina.
We'll grab that, too.
Combo.
Oh, no, I lost my combo.
I might want to...
You can change the color, by the way, of your little cursor.
And I feel like I might want to, you know, if it's
particularly difficult to see.
Making it more visible.
Yeah, you can.
It's pretty nice.
I wonder, though, hold on.
How do I do I do that?
Oh, there is.
Settings.
Let's see.
Maybe not.
I tried to do mint, you know, but maybe like...
a brighter pink or and i'm gonna make it i'm a grandma i
need it huge i need it bigger i need it bigger i need it
bigger it's pink
huh all right nice that should help that should help i like
it because it's pink
Let's do...
Unlock glowing spread.
Destroying a glowing piggy has a 20% chance to make one
nearby piggy glow.
That's pretty nice.
Double loot.
Let's get some of these like cheap, cheaper upgrades.
Hmm.
Ah, whoa, that seemed, that seemed pretty big.
I'm not gonna lie.
yeah oh no no my god hold
yeah yes phantom hand get them nice
holy cow we're making so much money now it's crazy steals
your coins and tries to escape smash him to get them back
with a 1.5 times multiplier the goblin
We'll upgrade.
This one's also attack speed, though.
Per 20 stamina I used on this run.
I'll do that.
How many days do I have left?
Three days?
We can get it back.
Hey.
Don't you dare.
I gotta just stand in there.
Oh, nice.
Huge.
Huge money.
On track.
Oh, gold.
Oh, no.
I almost got the golden piggy.
Dang it.
Trash boy.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Can you pick with piggy's show up or not?
I don't think so.
Doesn't seem like it.
They can't steal unless there are coins.
Oh, wait.
You're so right.
right oh golden gonna be gonna be golden i
didn't even get a guy that was trying to steal
investing on phantom ham maybe the move it could be it could
be it could be i mean
additional targets i can't do that one though or i could but
it's risky here let's do these two yeah cuz my bill is due
tomorrow whoa rage I'm raging out I'm raging out
yeah whoa
so much uh so much frozen nice give me more stamina please
oh no no pay our bill pay those bills pay a bill early each
early day gives back gives a 10 chance to get five percent
back oh you can get a refund eighth stream i come to after a
nightmare oh nice a game where you can get money no the
peggy is don't worry about them they they like it it's like
scratching a niche you know one hit there's a one percent
chance to make the to hit glow.
Glowing piggies give jackpots and always drop the highest
loot tier.
Oh, he's a semito!
He's a se!
Future comic can't find debt repayment.
I should take you.
I think a magnet would be good.
He'll just piggy wrangler option.
Yeah, let's do the magnet.
The bill, I'm afraid.
12,000.
Okay, we can do this.
We can do this.
we could we could do this we could do this
what was this one one million oh my god have we even seen
the coin rain i don't know if i have 5% of your base damage
per 30% loot bonus
okay one spread we did one time oh okay
I'm gonna get this one.
Wait, I didn't realize that would be the only one I get.
Set him on fire.
Set my pickies on fire.
Eventually, maybe.
Maybe they'll be set on fire.
Oh, they're coming!
They're getting close together!
I'm raging!
Whoa!
Okay.
That could have been better, that could have been better.
Hmm.
You know what?
Double or nothing!
Wow, it's been a while since we've, like, cleared the board.
You know?
Whoa!
That was a nice one.
It's a satisfying sequence of noises.
You know, that did sound like a lot of money.
And it was.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's go.
Miss two swings in a row and throw a tantrum.
We'll do the first hit of each run does two damage.
Oh, that gives us the more damage route.
Nice.
But it's $400,000.
It's like a...
I feel like, you know, the increment...
You know, usually in these types of games, it's very slow at
the beginning and then it like...
Snowballs.
But I feel like the snowballing here is not as much as I
expected.
Does that make sense?
It's a little slower.
Maybe because the rounds are so fast.
Like you're constantly
finishing them.
Whoa!
It's honestly pretty easy once you get ahead of the curve,
yeah?
I wonder if a better hammer would do better than some of the
skill tree stuff.
Oh, we could we can we can save up for the better hammer
I'll double enough in it
My seven thousand dollars That's fine Look I was trying to
get to the new hammer.
Okay
I got some achievement, but I didn't couldn't read what it
said
5,000.
Somebody leveled up.
You get low on pigs around halfway.
Yeah, maybe, like, investing in this one.
But when does my build do in two days?
We might be able to.
We'll do the respawn.
Um, I don't know.
Better accuracy with glasses on.
Okay, we can try.
If we had the full the screen full right i don't know should
i risk it for the biscuit having the piggies arrive faster
next bill maybe because i have two days to make back let's
let's uh let's yeah let's get see how close we get with this
one you know because it could be that we um have no issues
you know and are able to like handle it really easily you
know what I mean
if I have extra leftover
bro Tolito big brother of normalito it's normalito you smash
as a 70% chance to make bro Tolito appear okay cool
yeah I just I don't want to risk it i'm just scared i'm
scared oh get
this guy come on jackpot jackpot jackpot jackpot nice there
yeah took care of him oh
okay i think we could i think we could buy it uh guaranteed
crit while your stamina is below 10 wait that sounds crazy
plus two percent crit chance 30 why everything is crit wow
plus 30 crit damage but minus six percent crit chance this
one seems insane though i'm
gonna go with the third one all right and let's do faster
spawns What's our build?
34,000?
Okay.
Let's do this as well.
A higher loot.
Lightning.
Shockwave.
Respawn.
Rage.
Let's just keep going.
Keep getting these guys.
Bam.
Oh.
Got a nice little area.
Ah, dang it.
Let's...
I'm going to double or nothing it, you guys.
I'm going to double or nothing it.
Yes!
Okay.
That gave us a huge jump ahead.
That gave us a huge jump.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Nice!
I'm raging, I'm raging, I'm raging, I'm raging, I'm raging.
Oh, heck yeah.
Did I see a glowy guy?
Oh, no.
I don't know if we'll be able to get him.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come
on, come on, come on, yes!
Oh!
Alright.
um rage duration might be good yeah let's do that rage
chance i might even do the tantrum okay 34 000 okay um and
then the next hammer is 50 000
we're just casually setting piggies on fire Whoa!
Yes!
Oh my gosh, it feels so good.
Holy cow.
They're all gathered here.
Yes.
Yes, my piggy is give me money.
Who is this guy?
Okay, I'm just gonna continue for now before I decide what I
want to do.
Holy cow, holy cow, holy cow!
Yeah, get orb, get orb, get orb.
Nice.
Yeah, the magnet is crazy.
Orb activity.
spotted bet your coins watch the shuffle and smash the
correct one to double your money gambleito that's horrifying
I want to buy the new hammer so bad
how does this work oinky oink wait how does this I
don't- I want to see how it works first.
Right?
Oh, it's the shell game.
Oh gosh.
15k?
Okay.
I want to see how it plays first.
My eyes are drawing out.
Oh gosh.
Wait, I lost it!
I lost it.
Okay.
Oh, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm not committed.
Playback 0.1 speed.
Ban that guy.
This one!
We still have the money.
Ban that guy.
We're dead.
I'm never gonna get a new hammer now.
Oh yes.
The magnet, my beloved.
So
the past, it was the right one.
I mean, though, I left all my piggy banks somewhere.
I don't know.
You gotta watch over though.
Bad me if you must, Minto, but I stand by my guess.
I was wrong.
I regret nothing.
We'll get it back.
Watch this.
I'm broke.
Gambling addiction.
I have a gambling addiction!
Queen never cry.
We got this.
Anyway, next game.
Whoa.
Orbs.
Plus.
Plus magnet.
It's us.
Oh, double warbs.
Double arms.
Double magnet.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
You're mean to, you can have what's in my piggy bank.
I'm gonna get ice cream with that.
Thank you, Tona.
You got this?
I got this.
Ambling Addiction Fund.
I don't think that's a good thing.
It's a fund at all.
Admission is the first step to recut- Oh, there she goes
again.
Oh, our debt is due!
Each coin has 5% chance to duplicate itself.
I don't want this one, the minus 10% crit damage.
Each different piggy type you destroy adds 0.5% loot.
Moral of the story, gambling is very painful.
Yeah, it is.
Where's the money, Mintowski?
Yeah, I'm going to do the duplicate one.
All right.
What is it?
Like 50,000, 65.
We're never gonna get it.
I just went for some more luck.
Super jackpot.
Two million.
Oh.
Everybody, I fear.
I fear.
I just fear.
I fear that we won't get the next hammer.
You know?
I fear.
I have a great fear.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I fear.
Wow!
That was a good amount, though.
I want to double or nothing.
Oh, I want to double or nothing.
What if we make 20?
I mean, wait, what if we make 40,000?
I felt the rush.
See, it's really good when you win.
Oh, yeah.
How much time do we have five days?
I don't think it's all.
Even if...
That base damage Goes crazy hard though We might Do you
think we could make The $65,000 If I Big base damage I know
it's crazy Told you doubting you would work Always doubt me
Thanks, the blue cherry 50% of the times It works every time
so true i love your logic oh wow that was a really bad oops
just a wasted wasted first hit
they're on fire i always try to look out for the stamina
piggies
okay all right i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do
it new new hammer new new hammer new me new hammer new me
new hammer new me all right let's continue
wait i thought that was hitting both of them but it seems
not to be
holy cow and we cleared the board
i'm raging i'm raging i'm
guys we're gonna
go be dope next two times or nothing is on me yeah
Praise the new hammer!
Yeah, I think the hammer was a good investment.
Do it not!
But what if?
But what if we're there?
All right, let's grab some of these cheapo ones again.
We'll do like a lightning.
Things like that.
25.
I'm just looking at the pricing.
I'm shopping around.
Do not listen to the green goblig mask.
Make vill first, then double.
What's this one?
Oh, yeah.
Um.
Yeah, let's do that.
Okay.
Wait, this one too.
Rain, rain, rain.
let it rain let it rain let it rain all right that should
all oh hit this one okay that should be all like the three
thousand dollar ones
i like to get the ones that give me extra what's the word
extra um stamina those guys be real good
Everybody's just kind of...
Oh, I was going to say they're all kind of congregating for
no reason.
Wait, I think I got him.
Hey, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Alright.
Alright, let's continue.
Yes, yes.
Ooh, nice.
Ooh, we love to see it.
Oh, yeah.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Yes, we love to.
See it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's so much happening.
Oh, all of a sudden.
Oh, oh.
Hard!
What?
How did we get so much?
Maybe we got, like, a couple jackpots or something.
Because that one run was, like, 60,000.
It was insane.
How much is our next thing?
250,000 heavy hammer.
Whoa.
The base damage is crazy.
but there's a there's the attack speed is quite low
big jackpot payouts depend on your last run
low attack speed to the entire accuracy true bro telito has
a chance to drop 20k or something more gamba sure how do i
do it does it just do it automatically Then one day.
Alright, let's do it.
Cool.
Jackpot, buddy.
Bye-bye.
Yeah!
Huge money!
I'm raging.
I'm raging out.
Yeah.
42!
Oh!
Rocky!
Stone faced and not easily broken.
Wow!
Okay.
He's a toughie.
He's a toughie for sure.
Paying my bill.
5% loot from pickies!
Yeah, I'm just gonna do more loot.
Yeah.
My bill is...
200 everything thousand dollars yikes
what are you doing to get so much in debt comic cat happens
twice a year i don't know what to tell you
this part of roguelikes yeah right where you like it kind of
forces you into death a little bit you know
It forces you to die So that you, you know Then upgrade and
stuff And all that Like there's just a kind of Limit you can
do Before you can Oh, I got one though
Come on, please, please, please, please, please Yes
Yeah, you hit a wall.
Imagine the upgrades you'll have on your third run though.
Right.
What's this one?
Should I double it or nothing it?
I feel like we're not going to make this.
So I feel like might as well.
I feel like...
I mean, maybe.
What's this guy?
After paying a bill, your next run starts with plus 10
stamina.
A run save has been saved?
Possibly.
I'm just checking the pricing.
Okay.
Could go for the new hammer.
No, we can't.
Unfortunately.
It's too expensive.
We would not be able to make it.
Okay.
holy
I did get like the combo thing so that might help us like
get some mega money you know if our combos is high I'm
raging I'm raging I'm raging yeah
last one was on me but so is the next one the
run has been saved yeah Happy!
What's this?
Whoa.
How many days do I have?
Okay, we can spend a little bit more.
The shockwave, I don't even know if it does that much.
I mean, I guess we can improve the damage, but...
The hammer?
It's okay.
I don't think if we got the hammer, I don't think we'd be
able to make it at all.
Truly.
The hammer doesn't make you make more money.
We would need more piggies for that.
You know what I mean?
That's all dependent on our piggies.
Hey!
Don't take my money.
It will get you 100k per run, I believe.
You, you, you, you mean that?
Because I would have to get 250k.
It's cost 250k.
I would have to make that back in three days.
I would have to make that back.
I don't know.
100k?
He's done the math.
I think there's still one 3k upgrade left.
Oh, is there?
Did I miss it?
There's a 6k.
Uh.
3k upgrade.
Oh, there is.
Oh, my gosh.
You're so right.
The glowing spread.
Oh, thank you.
I totally missed it.
Bottom right.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I missed it completely.
Wait, that could be big.
Get the hammer.
I don't have enough for the hammer.
I would have to get it next time.
We'll get it next time.
There.
We'll just continue.
I could have done the piggy shuffle.
What if I had gotten it?
And then?
Oh, my glowing piggy.
Yes.
Glow.
Glow my piggy's glow.
I think I killed the Goode Goblin before.
Before I could steal.
All right, folks.
Here we go.
It's not destroying nearly as fast.
as i would like it to just saying i thought this was gonna
be a game changer
what if i double or nothing dead then we would make the
money back
thank you for being here
everybody if you don't sacrifice you don't make money
Thank you so much!
And breakfast!
I'll give you a full course meal!
How many days?
We have two days.
So let's grab a little bit some of the...
Damage per destroy.
Max 25.
we can grab some of the little more expensive one like these
this one two plus more piggies more piggies more piggies
never punished what do you guys want for dinner what do you
almost click that holy sheesh what do you guys want i'll
take you to the finest steakhouse you want bowl slop i'll
give you it you can get all the toppings you on.
Am I any good?
Shhh.
Shh.
Let's continue the game.
And then...
Let's just continue.
Shh.
My little... My little piggies.
Yes.
My little piggies.
Um, I need some glowing piggies here!
Mama needs to get out of debt Mama needs to pay her debt
Come on, please We cleared the board Ah Okay Gambling only
goes better the more you do it Nothing can go wrong Exactly,
exactly, exactly, exactly, exactly Exactly
um was there something else that i wanted to grab i don't
think so i'm not gonna do them why not yet
oh we leveled up somebody nice wow i really didn't think we
were gonna make this one no i definitely don't think we'll
make the next one but Every destroyed piggy has a 2% chance
to destroy one nearby!
I think that's better than the stamina.
Next hammer looking real juicy.
I called the last hammer.
Yeah, too easy, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Okay, okay, game.
Lost!
Keep smashing to discover this piggy.
Oh, jeez.
You just got out of jail.
I'm gonna get the Moai.
I don't care anymore.
Now this time I really...
I said before, but this time I really don't think we're
gonna be able to do it.
but i mean my gambling i will gamble every time you know hey
who said i'd be making a hundred thousand each day we should
call soul go into debt if you're if you're with a big tony
that's true
the 7k of the metagin tokens i bet you can get a lot of
rings for run three i think so too right yeah i'm gonna
double or nothing everything this time because i have
nothing to lose and everything to gain baby
oh yeah oh feels good i'm gonna get them awai all right
let's continue i don't know what this guy's gonna do he
might not do anything he might just sit there looking pretty
that's okay to Dude, I like watching pretty things.
Oh, he just zapped somebody.
He just, like, laser beam zapped them.
Let's go.
I think, like, next one.
I'll try to, like, what's the word?
Concentrate.
Maybe, like, on bigger routes or something.
Oh, I got him.
Sergeant Oink.
A tactical genius.
Marches in a straight line and turns at walls.
Okay.
Oh, ba-bomb.
Wow.
He will save us.
He will.
What's this do?
Spins across the deck.
Oh!
I want to try it.
We got a bay blade.
Where's my bay blade?
Oh, there he goes.
Nice.
Oh.
Let it rip.
They weren't kidding.
Wow.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
This is craziness.
I'm raging.
Oh.
They're on fire.
I'm on fire.
Let it rain.
Piggy rain.
So is he walking in a straight line?
I'm not really seeing the appeal.
Wouldn't it be crazy if I like...
Aw man.
I was gonna say if I like got it every time and somehow made
it to the 700,000.
How does she keep getting away with that?
I'm not getting away with anything!
like start the next you know oh my gosh wow orbs plus oh my
gosh wait this could be this could be huge this could be
really big come on please die please die nice 53,000 nice
but I like focus too I think.
Time for gumba.
No!
Oh, guys, it's so over.
I'm going to call Big Tony.
Help me out, man.
Help me out.
Need cash again?
I never have asked you for cash.
I got you, but you pay me back every cent.
Capiche?
Take 412,000 at 10%.
You owe 453,000.
Tony takes 5 to 10% of your earnings every day until you
repay the loan.
The cut does not reduce your debt.
Once you pay it back, Tony won't lend again for five days.
Hmm.
Lucky charm.
Might as well.
I got zero dollars.
And a lot of debt.
Ooh.
We got something new.
That's awesome.
these guys are kissing they're kissing they're kissing
they're kissing their soulmates they're so in love with each
other I love piggy breaking game I love piggy breaking game
it's really satisfying oh yikes yikes forever this is
terrible every 10th hammer hit restores 2% of your max
stamina wait that's nice Yikes, forever.
Platter
rip, platter rip.
Where's all my gold piggies?
This is why I'm being sabotaged against.
They've stopped the gold pigdom.
You ran out of luck.
Want to go for a new hammer?
I don't think I can.
It's a million.
I've never even seen that number before.
That's okay.
We'll just...
Honestly, I think I'm just gonna declare...
Well, we'll keep...
Oh, wait.
No, you only get the extra things.
If you, uh...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What is happening?
If you, um...
like the legacy coins if you pay the bill so honestly i
don't really need to oh
i didn't mean to get that guy what that would have been
awesome let's see yeah i'm just gonna declare by grossly i
think it's fine i think it's fine
all right time to spend you could get like so many things
you swing the hammer 15 faster i can't even get that so
let's get all the cheapo stuff first pay bills early to gain
plus two percent attack speed for early day maximum 25 does
it like every four days paid early everything is a days paid
early thing grab that first piggy you destroy each run
restores 15 stamina sure your first hit is guaranteed a crit
peggy loot is yeah 20 20 more damage oh i guess i could have
done these too stamina drains 10 slower we'll grab that
actually pay bills early swing the hammer we're gonna get
like the immediate things first you know what i mean Things
that benefit me.
We pay early sometimes, so I guess it's fine.
We're blinging hard.
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
Look at that.
What was this one?
30%.
Dang.
If only I got 30% more damage.
That's okay, though.
All right.
We're so slow.
But we kill in one hit.
we're making crazy money for our first oh yeah so then if i
pay this
whoa attack speed wait the circling warbs we'll get that one
yeah this will be such a better run honestly what if i just
pay my bill now let's do it let's get some early like early
damage and everything each different piggy type you destroy
the spikes 2% chance on every hit to trigger an earthquake
that cracks every piggy wow okay I'll try that that sounds
fun not it
attack speed spikes seem good we get that one quite often
though so I feel like I can uh oh dang it i feel like i can
uh hold off on getting i've never seen the earthquake one
before
oh come on i had that one
tourist is back okay
nice our hand is oh my gosh wait i didn't even notice that
we have it actually on our Yeah, we do have it on our hand.
That's so funny.
Like, all the rings and stuff.
That's crazy.
Wait, that's so funny.
Does
that mean, like, we die and...
What's the implication?
Like, we go...
We declare bankruptcy, and then we go into all this dead
again.
And we're, like...
We're...
We're then doing the piggybags all over again?
bank purgatory yeah right pay the bill hey 20 bills chain
reaction wait one percent loot per bill paid up to 12
percent now three percent loot bills paid the cycle three
one percent loot per bill paid yeah
we're just cogs in the system i will never will never win
lawyer's a bankruptcy lawyer it's a scary cycle
i feel like a train chain reaction is better i'll do that
one well maybe not better but um not yet not yet
let's see what am i buying 35 we'll get the cheapy ones
tippy tippy tippy tappa tappa
whoa oh no i almost had i was so close to 100 accuracy
wow that was huge
declaring bankruptcy to give more bling bling is expensive
it's expensive i'm gonna Double or nothing?
I want to play that voice game, the dubbing game.
I want to try it.
But I'm worried that I've seen like people's streams getting
taken down or whatever.
But I'm very good at impressions.
If you didn't know.
I think everything would sound.
the exact same oh come on as the original you would be very
impressed
can you do an Arnold get in the chopper maybe did a
workaround to stream it did she
Arnold on stream?
Had a fence in front of the scenes.
I see.
Arnie, is that you?
I thought it would...
Wait.
I guess it wouldn't be the audio that would get you struck,
right?
It's the visuals.
That's kind of messed up, though.
What if I want to show Homer Simpson Gif on my stream?
What if I want to show...
Mmm, what gets you struck?
Disney.
Disney GIF on my stripe.
Hmm.
Hello,
man.
Oh, wait, we want to get the better hammers.
That's right.
Oh, man.
Oh, hello.
I'm so used to them being one-hit wonders for me.
But I just immediately get...
Go off, go to the next piggy.
Yes, oh, no, come on.
Nice!
Ah, so close, so close, so close.
Start to take your upgrades for granted, you really do.
Let's see, let's grab this guy.
Would be a good opportunity to use Twitch.
Well, for the game?
Yeah, maybe.
I've never streamed on Twitch before.
Not, literally not even once ever.
Like, I don't know how to do it.
I don't know how to set up Twitch anything.
I would have no idea how to set up anything.
That'd be stupid.
Membership only?
Yeah, even that doesn't save you, though.
And I think I technically have, like, a strike on my account
at the moment.
So, I've been, like, debating.
if i should play it or not um basically i had a short that
went up and youtube did not like the name of the short
because they thought i was commanding people to do something
and so they flagged my they were like you're you're you're
asking people to do something unsafe and i i fought it i was
just like no i think you guys are wrong and you classic
YouTube was just like um no we're right actually it's it's
like okay whatever you say whatever you say I guess yeah the
fatal frame too and like the the title of the short was like
don't blink or something like that and they were like you're
you are you are acting you were asking people you are
commanding them not to blink and that is dangerous for their
eyes therefore we will strike your channel like hello
yeah don't blink you guys by the way it's so it's actually
it makes me a little upset because it's actually so stupid
like it's not even like a okay sure i'll give you you know
I'll give you a bit of a like a I understand No, I don't
understand It's so stinky
Haven't blinked since that short came out Don't sue me
please Don't sue me We should could probably pay this Yeah,
I'll pay it Nice.
Ooh, some max stamina.
Keep 15% of your bet when you lose a gamble.
I always knew you were an agent of Big Eye Street.
We live in blink by your orders, boss.
Okay, everybody, I'll tell you when to blink.
Eyes open?
Blink?
Eyes open, blink?
Close your eyes.
Imagine.
Imagine you're on a desert island.
You can only bring one thing.
What are you bringing?
Open your eyes, blink.
Close them.
Imagine.
Open your eyes, blink.
Close them.
Eye drops.
You win.
In fact, you win because...
It was a trick question.
The island.
the island was home to a cyclops with really dry eyes and
you give him you give him the eye drops and he says oh my
gosh thank you i was gonna eat you but now i can hydrate my
eye and i will get you home i was driving so this is why
your bike what do you mean
you can also command us to when to breathe breathe in hold
by the way this might be a funny time to mention that I'm a
ghost and I don't actually need to breathe so I'm not really
sure it's been a long long long long time since I've had to
breathe I just do I like kind of you know I'll go like so it
doesn't sound so weird for you guys like it sounds a little
bit more natural you know so I'm not really sure how long
you should be holding your breath for don't really know when
is like the appropriate normal amount of a of a human's lung
capacity hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold
hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold if you
hold it for longer the release is just gonna feel great you
guys it's gonna feel so good okay okay hold hold hold hold
hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold hold
hold
You're a ghost, you're cheating?
Winter, we about to pass.
You're a test.
Oh, well.
I died!
No, you didn't.
You didn't die.
You're perfectly okay, and you're right, yeah.
I want the next hammer.
We're gonna save up for that bad boy.
Gosh, I have so much stamina.
Now it feels like I have too much stamina.
Like, I don't know what to do with all of it, you know?
My accuracy for this one is gonna be abysmal.
Oh, we still passed!
Seize, get degrees, everybody.
How much is the next one?
4,000.
Okay.
If I die, can I go to the maid cafe?
If you're an urban explorer, you can come in in time.
Do Ibu's need to breathe?
Maybe.
I never really thought about it.
Aren't we also ghosts?
Right?
Lots of eye strain lately since I miss Minto a little every
time I Are you with the sideclops?
More damage.
We'll get those as well.
Hmm.
Guys, my tummy is starting to hoard again.
Oh, no.
No.
I haven't eaten that much today because it was hoarding
earlier.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
I love your sense of humor so much.
Thank you for being the silliest Billy this side of Goofy
town Thanks, Jackson, but my name's not Billy
It's willy as in silly willy I swim enough to where I can
hold it for a few minutes.
Whoa, wait, that's so awesome, actually
We'll get 3% damage and one pig Let's pay the bail.
You know I saw a comment on the Pal World VOD from yesterday
where I was talking about the Bacon Theater.
And someone was just like, how I said so many famous people
have performed here.
And all I named was comedians.
And he was like, you're not beating the allegations.
And I'm like, hey.
I only mention all of the comedians because they're the only
people I recognized.
Did I say Bill Murray?
But he's awesome, but he does acting too.
Attack speed, guaranteed crits while your stamina.
Whoa, the desperate strike.
Strength over stamina.
No, no, no.
Desperate.
I'm desperate.
That doesn't help either.
It doesn't help.
But I couldn't recognize so many of the other people.
Whoopi Goldberg was on there too.
Is she...
She's a talk show host.
No.
Actually, I don't know what she does.
I...
She's an actress?
Maybe.
Hi, hi, Minto.
I hope you're doing wonderfully.
Wonderfully eat.
Thank you, Brendan.
She was a comedian.
No.
No, she's an actress.
She's the actress.
She was in Ghost.
She was.
Oh, my...
My darling.
I hunger for...
Waffles.
I'm hungry.
But my tummy hurts at the same time.
let's do desperate strikes i'm desperate i'm in desperation
not yet
i'm making waffles oh to be a donkey oh to be a donkey in a
swamp who's making waffles it's so unfair so unfair more
piggy how much is our bill 27 okay we got this we got this
let's uh let's save for the ultra crit.
One,
two.
Very nice.
Got caught.
Give me that money all around.
I got to pay my debt down and I'm gonna go to the casino.
Ooh, pinjata.
You're amazing.
Am I?
I'm glad you think so.
Thank you.
Wow, that's a lot of money.
Phantom hand.
And he is the mean Pinkie.
What the cute?
Pinkie.
Thanks, Arsh.
By the way, random guests and bacon hotel staff were talking
about how the anime people are way better behaved than the
little kids and the Seinfeld fans.
Good job, guys.
Wait, really?
Oh, wait, that's a funny thing to mention, actually.
So, we apparently, I didn't know this.
Or actually, maybe I did hear this.
I don't remember.
But we did want the show.
The Skyline Serenade was on.
Friday we did want it to be on Saturday but we could not
have it on Saturday because because the wiggles booked the
theater oh man I hope they probably saw our show more sweat
and they were like man tough act to beat and I you could
have had a crossover.
The fruit salad, guys.
The very same.
Fruit.
But now I can say I've stood on the same stage that the
Wiggles were able to afford as well.
hey, Wiggles.
I'd say I'm mostly, not mostly.
I'd say I'm, my streams are fairly family friendly.
Some questionable.
I'd say they're PG-13.
So if the Wiggles ever wants to get a little, like, waggles,
you know?
I could have seen the Wiggles.
You could have!
From the Wiggles.
We're Wigglers to the Wiggles.
What a weekend.
Oh, I'm sorry.
My channel is not family-friendly.
I keep telling everybody not to blink.
Oh my gosh.
I'm also going to grab this plant and...
About it.
More crit.
Glowing chance.
Nice.
Explode for me.
Oh.
Peggy.
Woo!
Just don't play any more of those live stream etchy games
anymore.
I'm a shot.
The Q-Rate games?
Yeah, but there was a new one that I was thinking of
playing.
I don't know, you seem family friendly to me because you
love snakes and dinosaurs.
That makes me sound like I'm like a seven-year-old boy.
like oh yeah guys let me show you my new snake
don't talk about your reading material okay that that that's
true that's true that's true I have talked about my reading
materials with my the things I peruse let's see
I'm getting like the $1,200 once.
I said, I was like, oh, I feel like I expanded too broadly
with my skill tree.
And I did it again.
What's wrong with me?
We can make this back.
I just did it again.
I was like, oh, I'm going to concentrate on some stuff this
time.
And instead, I went all over the place once again.
I'm yeah, I'm just wiggling around I feel like though If I
wasn't a vtuber Or a ghost If I were alive I could be like I
feel like I could have Probably I would aim for Hollywood
Not Hollywood, sorry I would aim for Broadway And I would
One of those shoot for the moon And land amongst the stars
types of situations where I would aim for Broadway and I
would land under like mascot character for a children's
show.
I would be a teletubby.
This just in dozens of eyeballs get the clap after watching
the wiggles.
What does that mean?
Disneyland actor.
No, they are very specific.
Oh no, I could have been in, I could have been like goofy.
I could have been in a suit, I think.
But as a face character, no, no, no.
They're very specific.
Like, what sucks about, if you ever, like, want to audition
for Disney, their audition process makes me angry.
Because they already have an idea of, like, what character
they are trying to get?
How many days do I have left?
Two days.
before they even before like the audition so you could go in
being the perfect like I don't know the perfect aerial but
if they're looking for sleeping beauty like you're screwed
because they're like nah this audition is for sleeping
beauty but I guess they don't disclose that you just kind of
go to the casting calls and hope that they're that you are
what they want at the moment actually vtuber companies are
kind of similar too in that regard well where they'll have
characters you know typically already made and then yeah
sounds like some vtuber agencies yeah yeah yeah where they
so you kind of audition You could be like the greatest, most
entertaining, the funniest, the silliest, the most talented.
But if you don't fit one of the people that they have
already pre-made, then it's kind of, you know.
That's why you, if you want to try for a VTuber company, you
should try many, many, many, many, many, many times.
I watched Wicked on Broadway this weekend and the actress
who played Glinda.
She must have been improv-ing.
She had so much sass and extra character to her performance.
Wait, that's so awesome.
They're quite strict.
Well, uh, for, in terms of like certain Broadway musicals, I
guess they're more strict in terms of the improv you can do
in songs.
Like the, ah, is not really allowed on Broadway.
So they do the, ah, ah, on Broadway.
like a alphabet to do their own riff and if you got luck I
want me to be gassed on okay I can be gassed on it's a song
by them called I've got the clap and I'm giving it to you by
the wiggles mommy what does bleep mean until I'm boneless V
no not
a moribble flip it over look turn it around mm-hmm I'm out
of moribble, flip it around.
Wicked way!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I hit my mic.
I was... I was flailing my...
I was flailing my hand around.
My bed.
I'm gonna double it or nothing.
No!
We got cheated.
made some back.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, my skill tree.
Wait.
The bills.
Oh, when did we unlock this guy?
It must have been just now.
Let's go, Phantom Hand.
Nice.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Yes.
Big money.
Holy cow.
All right, I'll put...
Um...
Pay a bill early each early day gives a 10% chance to get 5%
back.
Wait, after losing a bet, your next run gets 100% luck.
Lucky loss!
Oh my god, oh my god, we're gambling forever, we're gambling
forever.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
oh my god we could do plus plus five damage i'm gonna pay
the bill uh after gambling win your next run pays one point
holy cow wait oh house never wins oh my god wait the gamble
run the gamble run wait this is insane we're gonna save up
for well i think the next uh i think the next hammer is
still maybe a bit of a ways away but yeah we'll be gambling
every time now guys it's part of the we'll we'll never lose
i mean we will lose but do we really lose
Losing is winning.
Double or nothing!
Easy.
I'm gonna pay the bill.
But I'm gonna get a couple upgrades first.
Let's see.
Let's get some cheap ones.
Oh, the combo.
The combo.
On the subject of the Wiggles, I'm curious.
What is your all-time favorite Wiggles song?
Who's your favorite wiggle or wiggle friend?
I really enjoyed the pirate.
I don't remember.
What was it?
Cappy the pirate.
Um, my favorite wiggle song.
My fruit salad.
I mean, fruit salad is like the only one that comes in my
brain.
Yeah, Captain Feather Sword.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm so sorry.
It was a parody band called The Giggles.
Oh, my God.
He's still there, is he?
There's a theme park that had like a little wiggles area
that I wanted to go to, but it's in Australia, I believe.
Faster swings.
Yeah, okay.
Two more piggies.
All right, let's pay.
And we'll get extra stuff.
Coin flip and shell wins.
Pay plus 20%?
Starting to run with plus one piggy.
Destroying a piggy has a 3% chance to go berserk.
50% less stamina drain.
I think we go high roller.
All in on gambling.
Yeah.
Like, I honestly don't see a reason to haunt it.
like we're paying we're currently we're currently paying our
bills early we're getting more strength because of it and
more piggies because of it and now we get to gamble as much
as we want with more reward than not
feels like Like, this is the run.
Feels like this is the run.
I might beat the roguelike.
You know what I mean?
I've got bad news about Wiggles World.
I know.
I've heard that it's not late.
Like they got rid of it or whatever.
Yahoo!
Yabadabadabadoo!
We'll do rage mode.
and tantrum because i keep missing
we have four days i'm gonna get the next one all right
our luck is going like we're starting with so many golden
piggies it's kind of awesome
i think he's gonna leave yeah he ate like all my coins i
understand i thought he was eating coins like off of the
table but actually seems like he's eating coins from my
stash over here
and then he tries to leave
I was just hungry yeah and I'm broke what does it want from
me
holy cow we just keep winning we just keep winning I can't
stop winning I'm gonna get that and we will pay our bill
woohoo crit combo 5% loot wait every crit in a run adds 10%
crit damage for that run up to 50% or more loot crazy gamble
run I know right He wants their coins because they're
chocolate coins.
Oh, that sounds yummy.
I'm gonna do the crit combo.
Can't wait for more announcements.
Ace Combat A at Tokyo Game Show.
I saw I got a... Line stamps?
Wait, no way!
There's line stamps?
I want that.
I'm gonna grab that.
And this.
Alright.
one thing i really want to get and now we're gonna try and
get the uh the um the magnet when we come magnet definitely
needs to be good eye oh nice nice gold pinky gold pinky yeah
baby oh jackpot oh yeah
i'm raging i don't know why i just am
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Dang, we lost a lot of money.
We lost so much money.
Oh, the piggy shuffle.
The piggy shuffle is back.
No, no.
I already lost.
Our luck will be better now.
We have the 100% luck this round.
Or we're supposed to.
If all goes well.
If all goes according to plan.
Do it.
Do what?
Oh no!
Don't get that guy yet!
It wasn't his time.
No!
I need them to eat my coins!
Alright, come on.
Come on.
Wow!
That was a lot.
This is up there for worst plans I've ever seen.
Say that again.
Where?
Worst plans you ever seen, huh?
Yeah?
I know, right?
Gosh.
What a failure of a plan.
Yeah, the new hammer.
We'll save up for it.
But for now, I'm going to pay this bill.
We can get it next time.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna do the berserk one.
Let's try that.
We'll get the next, we'll get the next one for the, uh.
We'll get the, uh, what's it called?
Alright, he's eating, he's eating, he's eating.
Alright.
I guess I could have waited, but I didn't want to get my
accuracy down.
I wonder how fast he is once he's full of coins.
Nice.
Yippee!
Aww.
I was hoping I would have enough
to buy the hammer.
The world's like zooming through this.
It's kind of crazy.
But I do There's some upgrades that I've won.
Oh, wait.
I couldn't see where my cursor was.
Oh, oops, dang it.
My brain sees Piggy.
It says destroy Piggy.
Double or nothing?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Um, am I in trouble?
Am I in trouble?
You're still fine?
Nevis!
Yeah, where's my 100% luck?
Honestly, I'm like, is it making a difference?
I'm quite wondering if it is.
Oh, bad when all the beta is done for two seconds, I read my
ESL super chat typing.
Typing in English is hard.
Don't feel bad, what are you talking about?
oh my god oh my god it's so over you guys it's so over
why i've lost the 50 like three times in a row now it's so
over
all i want is the other hammer this is so unfair and also to
not Go in the bankruptcy.
Oh!
He killed that guy.
Wow.
I didn't even notice he was up there.
Worst case you have Tony.
True.
Come on.
Please.
Please!
This is so unfair.
Where's my luck?
Four losses in a row.
It's 50% and I have four losses in a row.
That's crazy.
Oh, whoops.
I thought I was getting him, but I was not.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, he popped right up there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey,
we got something.
I'm just gonna pay it.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm not gonna pay it.
Yeah, we can do the next one, because I don't get anything
extra for it.
And then, hopefully, we can get enough to pay it, and
also...
We could also get enough to, uh...
Get the other hammer.
That's the goal.
Yes, yes, yes.
Berserk!
Yeah, insane of style.
What?
Oh, that's a lot of money.
That's a lot of money.
Come on, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please.
Yes!
Guys, we're almost at a million!
Huge!
The magnet!
Wait, bill bonus.
Plus 1% loot per bill paid up to 12%.
We can probably get that one later.
How much is a bill?
700,000.
Five days.
Let's grab some of these cheap ones.
Since I haven't really touched them.
25.
We'll go, like, less than 10,000 for right now.
I mean, that doesn't mean we won't get anything that is
above 10,000.
just for the sake of like you know yeah we'll do that one
okay okay I think this is pretty much this like almost the
same setup that we had before before we besides the table
spinner but I think this is about everything that we had
before as well now hopefully we can get like crazy you know
if we can get some mega luck we could like start paying our
bills early again and getting like more damage and
more damage and more what was the word
uh piggies was the second thing that it gives you
More stuff.
Oh, come on!
Poor goblin pig never has a chance to shine.
I know!
He gets destroyed so quickly.
Sometimes it's not me.
I don't mean to kill him.
Sometimes I do, but sometimes it's other things.
Yes, destroy, destroy, destroy.
Okay, let's not get him He's eating, he's eating He's
fleeing, he's fleeing Yeah
Whoa My
gosh Please Please, please, please, please, please, please
The richest Broke person Own $1 million at the once I got an
achievement Oh, yeah
I should have I should have paid the bill But I would have
only gotten one new piggy.
No more damage.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll get the top.
No, I didn't mean to get him.
My bad.
I thought he was one of these sergeant guys.
The Moai just casually laser beaming everybody.
We
got the new guy.
Bomb, Piggy.
One-shotting everything.
When it's...
HP hits zero, it lights its fuse and explodes destroying
nearby Piggy's.
I love that.
Ow!
Oh, finally!
Oh, nice.
All right, we're getting more Piggy's.
We're getting more Piggy's.
I'll hold off on the 450 Piggy one.
100, 1 million.
Okay.
This gets quite expensive now.
I can grab that one even.
25,000, I can grab that one.
Uh...
Like, we make obviously enough, but it is also still like, I
don't want to just be blowing $400,000 on upgrades
willy-nilly.
I'm not even reading what they do, I just look at the... I
just look at the price.
Okay, we need attack speed.
We don't really have just a dedicated attack speed anymore.
Oh, this one.
600,000.
We can get that next.
How many it is?
Yeah, we can get that next.
Oh, man.
That guy spawned at the worst place.
Oh, hello.
Oh, oh.
Oh, Gordon!
Oh, no!
Okay.
Yeah, he doesn't blow up very fast at all, right?
Thank you!
Oh, man.
It's okay.
One day.
What was I...
Was I saving up for anything?
Oh, the attack speed.
I still want to pay the bill and then do it.
Anybody else?
Nice.
We'll pay.
Okay.
I know I should have doubled it, but it's fine.
The first Piggy each run has a 50% chance to start Berserk.
10% crit damage.
Yeah, I'll do the crit.
Berserk, you think?
Three?
More Piggy?
I guess Piggy's is good too, huh?
Yeah.
We'll want more, honestly, right?
And then the attack speed.
How much is this?
Like 2 million?
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're at the 1 million.
That's right.
All right.
Let's go, team.
Keep on smashing.
Smash those pickies up.
Smash, smash, smash.
Yes.
Oh, he's special.
Nice, jackpot.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, and please.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Yes!
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice!
Whoa, we got a new guy.
Spiky.
Covered in spikes, any piggy that touches it takes 50% of
your base damage.
I like that all the piggies, like, kind of assist you.
Oh!
Plus one piggy.
I wish it would tell you.
You know, like, Say like, oh, if you get down to 4 days
left, you'll lose the piggy.
You know what I mean?
Because how will I know?
Yeah, it's too early.
I agree, but I want the piggy.
Is every 4 days paid early?
Is it now?
Let's see.
Skill tree.
We'll do like some of these I say smaller ones, but they're
like $100,000.
$165.
Wedge.
$2 million.
Super jackpot.
$1.4 million.
Yeah.
For every unlocked piggy type.
Oh, nice, nice.
We have a lot.
Numericans.
Ignite chance.
Fire lasts longer.
We could do that one.
Longer range.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We
shall start with two more baggies.
Six a million?
It's 10G.
I am paying my bills.
Oh my gosh.
It's chaos.
It's just absolute chaos.
Oh my god.
They all get together from the magnet.
spiky as heck.
Whoa!
Double or nothing?
We're gonna double it.
Told ya!
I told you so.
We'll do this one.
Phantom Hand.
One percent of your base damage per Piggy on Screed.
Yeah.
Oh, super jackpot.
Oh, wait.
I probably...
I'll be able to pay my bills, but it's likely.
I got too excited by the gold.
But doesn't Super Jack watch it sound really intriguing to
you guys as well?
Sure does for me.
Wow, almost 2 million there.
It was worth.
It was so worth.
I'm gonna pay it.
A variety bonus.
Big swing.
We'll do luck.
More luck is nice.
Okay, 4 million.
We could do this.
I can't even see, like, anything.
Games like these get so funny because you literally can't
see anything like once it goes insane oh style it's just
like oh my gosh
i'm watching oh no oh he burst into 24 000 oh nice why
am i not destroying anything
look at all the pieces uh watch this oh don't watch that
maybe look maybe avert your eyes Rainbow Piggy incoming,
yeah.
I'm very excited for that one.
Sometimes the guys are such unlucky, the loot goblin guy has
such an unlucky spawn.
Because he gets killed like right away.
Watch this.
Don't...
Actually, I'm shy.
I have performance anxiety!
Don't watch it!
I lied, I lied, I lied!
I told a fib, I told a Disney lie, and now I can't get out
of it.
Disney lies stress me out.
Do you guys know what a Disney lie is?
It's when somebody...
Like, I call it...
Like, they're called Disney lies because, like, they start
out, like, silly.
They'll be, like, someone lies about something.
And then...
They have to cover their stories so much.
They end up, like...
They'll be like, oh yeah, my dad works at Nintendo.
Rarely shows up, but drops lots of loot!
Yeah, I do.
Yeah, the snowball effect, exactly, exactly.
My eyes are still closed from last blink quarter.
Watch this.
Oh, no, I shouldn't have said it!
I jinxed myself!
wait this
could be our biggest haul yet you guys I saw a jackpot and I
don't know from hoops was it the rightful piggy did he grace
us with a jackpot
they said rarely shows up but hello we've gotten twice wait
maybe because my luck is Is, is crazy right now.
Pay more bills to fill up this piggy.
What?
I am
humble.
Ah!
Oh my god!
The golden hammer.
I bought everything in the shop.
I got an achievement for it.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Last stand.
When stamina runs out, fire at every piggy for 25% of your
base damage each.
Whoa.
Piggy shockwave.
Let's get these two.
Whoa.
Cool.
Okay.
I'm just going to continue.
It's just chaos.
Still, though, it sounds still very satisfying to my ears.
You know?
It still sounds quite satisfying to me though.
Wait, who are...
Who is this guy?
When did I get this guy?
Did I just get him?
Nice!
New Pigies didn't even get introduced.
Yeah, I don't know this guy.
Who are you?
I think though, we'll get this guy.
Who the heck are you?
Oh, Viking.
Brave, tough, and hard to smash.
Smash this piggy to level up to increase its loot by 5%.
Ah, I see.
Oh, that's fair, Bill.
Berserk start.
Crit's chance, brute force.
We'll do the berserk start.
Holy cow.
I can't see anything.
get some of these like lower ones like 200,000 and less
unlock nearby skill like this what's our new bill seven
million seven million you guys seven million six a million
if the first piggy each run spawns glowing that's so
one foot per piggy on screen
I'm just looking at prices
yeah we're in like the one everything almost everything is
one million now what is last stand when you're standing
around this one you know what why not right
Why not?
Why not grab it?
Though I wish I could get more piggies, you know?
Oh, nice.
Nice.
More piggies and more chaos.
Well, it's because, like, by the end, like...
Oh,
we got a new coin.
Piggy count kind of acts like a soft cap on your earnings, I
guess.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
What'd we get?
Which one?
This one.
Plus two Piggy spawn.
Lucky, lucky.
Let's just continue.
Come on.
Destroy.
Destroy these guys.
Increase their loot.
it's good to get the bomb ones especially if they're like
around these heavy duty guys they really just explode and
like unleash it all rainbow guy he's been
eaten I'm still worried about our earnings no I'm worried
about our earnings because I'm kind of like we're making
like what two million Man, we need to make more.
You know what I mean?
We need more money.
We kind of need, like, more money to happen.
Yeah, we're kind of cutting it close.
Second win.
We need more cash.
I
don't know.
I don't think the golden piggy disappears, but I'm kind of
treating him like he does.
I'm scared.
I don't want him to leave me.
He leaves with so much cash too.
Nice.
Need more piggy respawn chance.
Might need it, yeah.
Because right now...
Like, it's fine.
Oh, see, this was a good one.
This was a good run.
And then if we double it, hopefully, I'm humble.
I am humble, please.
No, oh.
I think we might be screwed.
This is my 100% luck.
Or whatever it's supposed to be.
Where is my crazy luck that should be occurring right now?
It's gone.
No, it's not!
It says every time I lose, I get luckier.
Isn't that how it's supposed to be?
Oh, nice.
There's a dead-o!
99% of gamblers give up before...
Oh, Tony never figured out how to open it.
Smash it to reduce his cut by 10%.
Tony's pig!
Oh.
Wait, but I have enough.
Maybe I shouldn't.
I'm gonna do it.
Okay.
My thing about this game is I wish there was more stuff in
the shop.
Like, the skill tree is fine, but I've maxed.
There's still even one piggy that I haven't discovered yet.
Are these, like, Buku Bucks?
Is this Tony's guys?
Hey, Tony.
Who's your guys?
I like when they all congregate and then get blown up by
this.
guy who's your guys who's your guys wait where's my cursor
there's nice
oh they do explode or they do like eventually okay very good
wow no
it's okay we can still play the bow every five seconds
there's and mark and destroy a random piggy.
Or each coin has a 1% chance to convert to a jam.
Jam.
Jammy, jam, jam, jam.
We just lost 6 million.
It's okay.
1 million refund.
They love us.
16 million.
They don't love us.
How did I get into such debt?
How did this happen?
What?
with the shadiest people of all time.
I'm gonna do this one.
Oh.
Whoa.
And it's cheap.
Okay.
High pay for high reward.
I think he's crossed.
Now we get a high amount back, you know?
Like the sound of that.
Yeah.
it's always high risk high reward everybody oh
my gosh this guy is a jackpot holy cow
I get all this debt says the gamble goblin how did I how do
I lose why do I keep losing why
why why does
not kiss me today the maiden of luck
Watch this.
I'm gonna say that.
Oh my gosh, I'm so stupid.
I don't think me saying watch this.
Has worked even one.
It has not worked.
Even one time.
Lucky piggy.
Lucky little piggy.
Piggy, shiny Piggy.
Come on.
Come on by shiny.
Come on by shiny Piggy.
Oh, super jackpot!
Oh my god.
Guys, this is not a drill.
This is not a drill.
Super jackpot.
Unlock every piggy bank.
Hit the super jackpot once.
Hard to break, but full of loot.
A walking jackpot.
Oh Trophy
Say the line
Watch this Feel
so good feel so good feel so good feel so good feel so good
Rock ran
watch that oh yeah oh yeah i'm gonna get this one this the
glowy one super jackpot super jackpot
say ball out on upgrades until you can't yeah pretty much uh
i'll do like stuff like shockwave divine rays i don't even
know what those are i think i've seen them probably you're
mentioning the movement exhibit at the nyc botanical garden
but I ended up going Saturday but spend most of the time
exploring the conservatory and outside gardens exhibit
itself is fun fun that sounds so nice yeah from what I
understood the movement exhibit was like how many days two
days it was like just like a very kind of not minimal but
like there wasn't so much to do with it so some people were
saying that like reviews I was reading online were saying
that it's like you know nice but yeah some cheap upgrades
yeah oh there we go shockwave chance I don't want to do too
much though oh this guy is This is a walking jackpot,
jackpot.
Wait, did I get them?
I actually have no idea.
Nice.
Oh, here, here, here, here.
I'm raging, I'm raging, I'm raging, yes, yes.
I wonder how much we'll get now.
Yes.
Yes, break apart my little piggies.
Oh, yes, good, good, good.
Come over here, come over here.
Nice.
Ore no mint!
I love it!
Naosare!
Yatou!
Zupa, thank you!
Thank you!
Better for you, Miss.
Vince, this is your wife.
You have to come home from the casino.
Your kids miss you.
I miss you.
Yeah, but I'm thinking of the kids as college fines.
and watch this I lost it all
my super we got so lucky with like the golden piggies and we
lost it all the winner takes it all the loser has to fall A
winner or a pig will smash him regardless.
Oh, Super Jackpot!
Please, I want a bomb guy.
Imagine if I had doubled the last one, though.
Oh, thank goodness.
the college funds stamina oh we can finally do this the bill
bonus we'll do that one more money more money we'll do the
rock rain oh
what's our new bill 24 million okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay we'll do this one let's let's max out like anything
that has to do with money or not max out but you know 10
million
stuff like this you know
we need damage in aoe I mean yes but also money
this one's cheap oh nice nice combo combo oh nice nice nice
that one's cheap that one's cheap that one's This one's
cheap.
This one's cheap.
Cheap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
More damage!
Ooh.
All right.
It's 24.
We're still at about 10 million.
And we have how many days?
Five days.
I believe in us.
Let's go for it.
I'm raging.
All right.
Go,
go, go, go, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Super Jacobite!
Guys, I think we're going to make a lot of money.
Trust.
I think we're gonna make a lot of money.
Trust, trust.
Oh, actually.
Oh, new coin.
It wasn't so good.
It was okay.
It could have been so much better.
Okay, but watch this.
You guys are jank-sing me.
Actually, I think if you guys say it, it's better than if I
say it.
What did we get?
If your first swing hits two piggies, that swing deals 20%
damage or plus 20% damage the
gold pickies like are so tough they don't even it doesn't
even look like they turn red at all like they're just crazy
tough the one on fires for the one I'm trying to get these
are golden goose yeah oh
yeah get the bomb get the bomb get the bomb yeah I wish I'm
sure we could get more bomb buddies.
Mom bomb pick-pickies.
That guy was 20 million alone?
Holy moly.
Nice.
Let's just unlock these.
In fact, I'm gonna get the super jackpot chance.
100 million.
Nice, nice, nice.
I think you'll make your next bill.
You think so?
You think I'm gonna make it, Doc?
I think I'm gonna make it, Doc!
Oh my gosh.
I believe.
I was gonna not stream for so long today, but...
Addicting games are addicting, huh?
Oopsie.
Oopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
Especially because I have stuff to do after this, but...
We're almost, like...
At all the upgrades.
We almost have, like, the entire skill tree unlocked.
it's kind of insane
all right let's go the bills must be paid what happens if i
unlock everything i guess like oh my god another yes yes oh
my god oh my god did i get him i think so No, I didn't.
He's still here.
Or there's a second one.
Please, just die!
Oh, we got him, finally.
Oh, oh, there's a second one!
There's another one!
Oh, my gosh!
Come on!
Please die!
I need your money real bad.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
gosh i can't tell what's going on i
think it's better now actually it is it was hurting earlier
but it's okay right now yippee oh not yippee not yippee a
little less than yippee all of these are 40 million we could
do the this one the 10 million i took out i did one 10
million still got 12 million yeah but imagine what we could
have gotten
imagine what could have been
gosh whoa we did the one smash on him nice
super jack of war oh this game has such a nice sound
everything is sound so like crispy, you know?
Oh, nice.
Come
on.
Let's go.
Come on.
Oh my gosh, my stamina is good.
Oh, nice.
I don't know how I keep getting stamina.
Oh, I think it's because of like the...
Oh, man.
Because of like the one last chance and everything.
Oh!
Yeah!
Alright, let's grab some of these.
100 million.
You know what?
Now is the chance to grab it.
Now is the chance.
Now is the time.
Respawn.
We'll do that even too.
What's the bill?
24?
All right.
Well, we have one more day.
25.
30.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, another one.
Yes!
Wait, did I one smash it or did he get caught in the
crosshairs of, you know, of all the chaos?
My one smash piggy.
I'm raging out, I'm raging out, I'm raging out, I'm raging
out.
Oh yes, explode!
Impossible to tell.
Hog wild!
Yeah, I'd say so.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Use your rate.
Oh.
I'm raging because I keep losing the 50-50.
Wide swing.
Lucky swing.
More damage.
25% chance to start each run with Plus 25% hit radius.
I'm afraid it's terminal.
It's only going to get worse.
I've contracted the phantom virus.
The only relief is a Minto stream.
Why is it?
Why did you ride it like a shit post?
Like one of those emoji things that's just like...
I love the Christmas ones or the turkey ones that are
like...
Hey, baby daddy.
I want to gobble, gobble on some stuffing this year.
You know what I'm doing?
Damage might be good.
Yeah, we'll do damage.
Stop.
You know what I'm talking about, though, right?
Our bill is 36 million.
I think we've got this in the bag, baby.
But...
I can't really...
I mean, I can't afford.
I can't afford.
afford one like one upgrade i think we can make it back i
think we can make it back i'm not getting greedy maybe
a little greedy oh
oh oh stop running stop running yes very good very good
Did that get anybody?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, oh, nice.
Double or nothing.
I can't actually even afford anything.
Um, yeah, we're basically, I feel like we've done, like,
almost the max this game has, you know.
Like, it almost feels like we've beaten it at this point.
But, there's, you know, still a few skill trees to unlock.
Still a few things, yeah.
At this point, it's just kind of, like, almost like
grinding.
Like, where I'm just trying to get to the next thing.
On second run, too.
Yeah, you're so right!
Maybe we're cracked.
I think that the increments are very generous in this game
though.
Oh!
Oh my god!
It flipped!
Wow!
Yeah, the increments are not nearly as like brutal as a...
What's the word?
Um...
Like Clover Pit or something like that.
The bill is 36 million in...
three days.
What's this one?
Rock rain.
14 more rocks.
Blast radius.
Let's do this one.
Well, it's not that much cheaper.
We'll do the...
More damage.
Pay it.
Extra pig.
Well, that's three days.
But we can't buy any more pigs that is true like we are out
of pigs so i mean i'm gonna pay it yeah i don't think i've
seen the rocks either i've seen the divine thing but i don't
know if i've seen the rocks speed 10 oh no doubt we'll do
the big two percent unhit 2 percent chance to get 1.5 hit
radius for three swings we'll do the crit chance
Yeah, I'm like determined I feel less like, you know, I have
to keep going, but now I feel like not a sunk cost fallacy,
but I'm just like, yeah, I'm so close, you know.
I'm so close.
All it takes is a couple good hits, a couple good, you know.
We're so close.
Wait.
Nice, that guy took out so many.
He ran over there like he was so excited to blow everybody
up.
He was like, yeah, I'm gonna kill them all.
I'm gonna kill them all.
Look at these ones.
I was gonna go for the gold ones, but...
Wow!
New coin.
Oh my...
Oh my god!
Can we unlock everything now?
With no consequence?
56?
Yeah.
What?
No achievement for getting the whole skill tree unlocked!
The first piggy you destroy each run, 33% chance for three
times.
What's left when everything's upgraded?
Um...
There's... Oh no, we do have all the piggies.
What is left?
Uh, this coin, I guess?
Hold on.
Oh, the trophy, yeah.
We're trying to fill in the trophy.
Whoa.
King piggy bank.
What is a king piggy bank?
Wait, what is this?
King piggy bank and 30% attack speed, 30% damage.
Damage.
Wait, what is this?
Damage?
Whoa!
King Piggy.
Oh, I got that King Piggy.
Oh my god.
That is a lot of damage.
That is a lot of crit damage.
That is a lot of attack speed.
We'll do crit damage.
Whoa, oh my god,
complete the full coin collection.
We got the last coin!
Take him out!
Bomb, nice bomb, nice bomb, nice bomb.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Take him out!
Nice bomb, nice bomb, nice bomb.
damage but that's okay oh my gosh did
i do it you're not broke anymore no more bills no more pass
due notices nothing left to pay at least that's what you
think but there is one bill you have not paid yet that's
all my money what if i call big tony my taxes anyway
what's the money for what who stop calling me no
freedom pay your taxes oh no sorry pay all your bills
wait i smashed only one oh wait oh i if the game was gonna
be one of those like never ending like incremental increment
increase incremental games i was going to spend it all on
this guy at the very end after paying your taxes of 1.13
point Or 113.67 million.
You're now sitting at a net worth of $1.
Yay!
We beat it.
That was fun.
Gamer Garden.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
Yay!
At least you're in the green.
You have a dollar to my name, everybody.
Let's go get...
Bubblegum on me.
Wait.
No, I only have my dollar.
Hold on.
I want to try.
One last thing, guys.
One last thing.
We're going to do the green piggy.
We're going to bet it all.
I will do a poll.
Whoever says the right thing gets a big smooch on the cheek.
If we get our money back.
okay this is this is everything this is huge
walk in yeah walk in
gosh the magnet was so helpful
one last time hearing all the little breaking noises
everything so satisfying and lovely
oh there is still this though.
I wonder if that's like a trophy too.
The right thing.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
That's not what I meant to say.
Ah!
Wait.
Okay, one more time.
Whoopsie.
Wait, I didn't mean to do... Continue.
Wait.
I actually did want to go to the green guy.
I did actually want to go to the green guy.
We'll do it.
We'll do it right after this.
What?
smash but
that's okay we'll just have that much more money to bet
it'll be great it'll be so good it'll be so good
it's so quiet sometimes
you can fill out the skill tree too so true like actually
fill it out okay upgrades there we go what there's even more
That's okay though, it's okay.
The piggy shuffle is where it's at, everybody.
If we win, we could get 316 million!
Oh, oh, shoot.
I clicked out of the game, so the audio stopped.
Wait, hold on.
I'm making the poll.
Which piggy?
Left.
Middle.
Here we go.
Dun,
dun, dun, dun, dun.
Dun, dun, dun.
What?
Oh, the pool is going down.
It's left in the lead.
Dun, dun, dun.
Oh, it left is going down.
Oh, it's going up.
All right.
You guys have 20 seconds because of the lag.
20, 19, 18, 17, 16, 15, 14, 13, 12, 11, 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5,
4, 3, 2, 1,
Is it always on the right?
Yeah, unlock all rings.
Thanks for helping me pay my bills.
It was great.
I mean, it was the right one again.
I had so much fun.
I hope you guys did too.
Amazing job.
The only thing that couldn't beat the taxman.
Hope you had a good rest.
A good rest.
Something, something.
Thank you.
Thank you for...
Rest and glitchways, thank you for that, Guiperいく.
This little piggy went to the market.
This little piggy stayed home.
This little piggy had roast beef.
This little piggy had none.
And all the piggies went wee-wee-wee as they got smashed
under Minto's mighty hammer.
Well done.
Good night.
Thank you, everyone.
Otsumito!
It's Otsumito!
Eat that asia!
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye!
Thank you, thanks.
What do you, wow?
Welcome back!
Rest and glitchways, Otsumito!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye!
What's up, you guys?
Thank you!
Bye-bye!